so I'm in a little bit of a pickle my
husband wants to buy a brand new stop by
side yesterday we Clos in our house we
will take home a little over 33,000 on
it you sold your house paid for you sold
your house house okay you got 33 $30,000
in your pocket I convinced him to take
29,000 of that and pay off his truck and
now he wants to go buy a brand new stop
outside and I'm like but we have other
things I need to pay for and I keep
telling him no and he keeps saying I we
we have money now I'm like we don't we
don't have money you don't have the
money to buy side by side right no okay
so he's talking about talking about this
is the same man that yesterday paid off
his truck and now he wants to go back in
debt so he's not really on the get out
of debt plan he's just kind of going
along when you tell him to do something
until he doesn't want to do it so this
is not a money problem this is a husband
problem